what's up reject nation I'm Greg who are
you
I'm Aaron got my friend Aaron here today
he has been religiously quarantine and
now that California is almost reopened
completely I mean if gyms are open I
could bring Aaron by he's been safe
right yeah sorry about that
[Laughter]
you can tell ironshirt that he is a DC
fan why would you do this to me in today
Aaron why because it's one or the other
I can't like both Aaron I know we're
gonna watch some emergency awesome today
Suicide Squad to comic-con teaser
announcement the Batman DC 2020 trailer
breakdown and I'm assuming they'll be
covering that con which I've only seen
headlines of but haven't fully read into
any Hill Aaron have you seen emergency
awesome I've dabbled I've emergency with
some awesome I'm glad you're back
I dig this song
that's Suicide Squad oh man is gonna be
a great event please please do well
James Gunn I believe in here welcome
back everyone
is Charlie this is going to be my new DC
Comic Con trailer video they just
released details on the online version
of comic-con that they're doing this
summer all the trailers and the footage
that are going to release new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get just
waited for emergency awesome do this
video part of that stuff too but big
details number five first big thing is
the actual Comic Con 2020 event DC is
doing their own Comic Con Saturday
August 22nd like that teaser says just
because the virus you're so because
there's no big Hall H panel for any of
the studios so it's said that they're
doing their own separate event by
themselves it's not just gonna be a
giant zoom call with Robert to make it
feel more like an interactive experience
on a special website that they're gonna
create for it fascinating panels on
their YouTube channels or anything like
that everything will be coming from one
of their websites they assume it's gonna
be like a supercharged version of HBO
Max or the DC streaming service and then
they'll just post all that content and
all the panels on there forever unless
they roll it into the main DC website
later it'll be available to everyone
around the world so don't worry they'll
be posting about that on their social
channels in August so don't worry about
missing any of the information of these
videos about that stuff then - anyway
access to all that content but it'll
either be super cheap like way cheaper
than buying a ticket to the actual Comic
Con in real life or it'll be free and
they'll just pay for it through the cost
of all the merch that they sell there's
going to be a separate San Diego birth
Comicon event online during the weeks of
July that the normal comic-con would
have happened but they haven't announced
what panels are gonna happen during that
but like I said because there is no big
Hall H event happening for any of the
studios everyone at all the different
studios Marvel DC are releasing their
comic-con trailers differently this year
okay about the Marvel stuff at the end
of the video after I talked about all
the DC trailers that they're gonna
release damn straight you see trailers
and footage that they're going to
release or happening at the DC fandom
comic-con enough that's gonna be a great
day hopefully that clears up some of the
confusion I'm sure people won't see this
video and they'll still be asking
questions about it in a month so don't
worry I'll remind people when I do more
videos about DC stuff thank you are they
actually going to be doing at this event
so number four DC announced that they're
gonna be doing panels for pretty much
every single movie and TV show and video
game that they have right now
we're coming up with a new Arkham game
game the defense isn't for a while there
is going to be a lot of video movies
coming out in October now right after
the panel watch game plays there's even
gonna be a comic-con panel for the Black
Adam movie it's actually which comic-con
trailers in footage actually going to
show up describing it they're dropping
first looks for the Justice League
Snyder okay who didn't need the upcoming
TV shows which they'll also be dropping
teasers for too but because of the virus
people haven't been filming anything
so there's PI not gonna be a ton of TV
footage for them to show off you can
specify whether or not they'd be
releasing more concept teasers or
previews of the big-budget HBO Green
Lanterns and Justice League dark or the
other DC HBO series that they're doing
you're welcome Canada is gonna be on the
upcoming movies in the TV shows Jim Lee
said they'd be doing a lot of video
manthis not uncut study night
their new big Batman game reveal with
some footage but I know less about
what's going on with the new video game
stuff than I do about the movies and the
TV shows I just know a beginning a lot
of questions about possible Batman games
I got three video games to beat in the
next probably a full Catwoman reveal in
the costume the villain reveals for the
penguin the Riddler a better preview of
the new Batmobile in a much much cleaner
look at Robert Pattinson's new Batman
he's gonna come out all inspiration for
this new version of Batman without being
super spoilery about it we already know
it's gonna be more of a detective
neo-noir type of story based on Batman
the long Halloween so hopefully he'll
just clarify some of that the new
Suicide Squad movie finished filming a
long time ago so they have all Suicide
Squad trailer but James Dunne will
probably explain more about how his new
movie is related to the previous Suicide
Squad movie because technically it's not
supposed to be a reboot and when they
said that my assumption was they would
just explain that something terrible or
hilarious happened to the previous
quote-unquote version of the team a
there will be everybody from the first
movie but something happens and Amanda
Waller just needs to put a new version
of the team together I did a video for
the first time last year and they were a
kind of super weird deep cut characters
from the comics everyone was confused
why their costumes seemed so comic book
II in over-the-top my early prediction
at the time was that that was just part
of the joke of the movie that the team
is supposed to be expendable it'll have
a version of the team at the beginning
of the movie that just gets killed off
in some hilarious way before they
introduced the actual team even though
Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn like
exposion yeah with the birds of prey
movie or anything like that it just said
during a different period in her life
when she's not with the birds of prey
but because it's still her and because
it's not a
the movie is still connected to Justice
League and the other DC EU movies so
we'll see what kind of Eastern also
clarified the Jared Leto's Joker is not
going to be involved with the Mulsanne
yeah right
this is Flula Borg if you can believe it
and Pete Davison is also playing a
character yeah he just part of a team
gets killed off in some hilarious way
they're doing a new version of king
shark suite movie playing peacemaker
dave bautista was actually going to be
in the movie to talk about james gunn
guardians of the galaxy but there was a
scheduling conflict he's playing the
character peacemaker that dave bautista
would have played it even for us where
her Easter eggs hang out YTD is also
playing a character during the movie
mystery so it might wind up being
another big number one obviously
everyone's also asking what about
marbles comic-con panel or that's why
you're wearing the shirt it's gonna come
out of comics that doesn't include any
of the Mandalorian season queue and the
Star Wars stuff that they're working on
separately so if you guys don't remember
Marvel has actually already done a
version of what DC is doing this year
too in the past a couple years ago Kevin
Feige said that they weren't ready to
announce everything for Marvel phase 3
at the July comic-con haul age panel so
a little while later in the year a major
event he invited a bunch of journalists
reveal event until then all their Marvel
phase 3 movie plans that they had not
revealed in Hall age about Benedict
Cumberbatch becoming they will probably
use it to release their full Avengers
Falcon and Winter Soldier trailer a
wonda vision trailer and maybe the
first Marvel Eternals trailer remember
all this stuff isn't kicking off till
August 22nd for all the DC trailers and
footage so don't worry about missing
that they'll be making a whole bunch
more noise about that when we get to
August everyone click here for that
Suicide Squad so far sweet let's talk
about some of this stuff he's doing from
a very biased level from an extremely
biased level I'm very happy that this DC
event is separate from comical because
it makes it significantly easier to
cover the event I went to comic-con last
year where do we went to comic-con last
yeah you read Hall H last year I was and
if you guys might have heard me say this
before comic-con is really just really
not my thing I won't because I was
offered to host the panel it's cool look
around it's exciting I appreciate the
fandom I appreciate the love and joy
that everyone has for it my end I'm like
I'd rather just go back to the hotel and
cover whatever's coming there's exciting
but so from a biased level of being able
to cover stuff on YouTube I'm excited
that this is gonna be a separate event
it's gonna be very focused as opposed to
DC stuff coming up we got Marvel stuff
coming out we got these other movie
stuff scrambles exhausting I feel like
they'll have a chance to really dive
more in depth I'll release to do for the
online community is give us some cool
trailers and some cool footage right
that's all we really need there could be
that downside where people come out of
this experiment told DC event and even
show as much didn't give us much it was
just panels and interviews which can't
be cool a lot of people will appreciate
that but what we really need is some
footage and then for me the two things I
want most the Suicide Squad trailer and
footage of what Zack Snyder is doing
with the Snyder be good those are the
two main things what about you
I want the Batman I want okay man and I
also won Suicide Squad I'm curious how
much they're gonna show as opposed to
how much they would have shown if it was
an actual comic-con I know because it's
comic-con it's a small audience with Rio
we get to show a little tidbit maybe
like
five minutes six minutes ten minutes of
footage from this movie that's coming
out but because I the entire world and
you know piracy is a thing and just like
why'd production of videos of things
work they're gonna show like 30 seconds
or like a minute as opposed to what we
could have gotten but hey something's
better than nothing right absolutely I
mean I think comic I think if this goes
well it's the interesting thing about
what this pandemic has done it's it's
forced a lot of us to experiment what we
can do that's more online or more from
home in more ways than just like these
events everyone knows what I'm talking
about it and work-related process or
whatever and if this event goes well and
let's say next year they're able to have
people attend an actual comic-con in
person again they might just do another
DC event the way they have there's like
d23 expo they could just do this as well
they think they could see a bigger
profit
and to have their event be a month after
comic-con and where everyone is solely
focused for like a day or two only on DC
this could be something that really
changes the game for them no 100% I
think that was really smart of them to
give it a whole month after comic-con
give them the space to be able to thrive
and get the attention that they I'm sure
they would desire now what I'm hoping
for is Marvel does their event the exact
same day just do it like an hour earlier
[Laughter]
trailers like a minute before I didn't
realize Suicide Squad was done already I
thought that was still being shot for
some reason no I think that would feel
like out of all these movies I think I
feel like that one has the greatest
chance to probably come out closest to
its release date sure I did a lot of the
filming boy I mean then we gotta get a
follow-up Wonder Woman trailer that's
true I mean I would I imagine what we'll
be getting or trailers for trailers
leading up to this event of like a
little snippet or like 15 to 30 seconds
tune in August 22nd for the DC event you
know we're gonna be doing a lot of that
but it's gonna be teases yeah it's gonna
be excited for the Snider cut Department
because um I'm just pandering in the
Snider cut out now well these are not
excited I'm not I'm so far from excited
no it's because
you know how for the longest time it's
like people have done here's the footage
from the trailers that was not in the
movie that we got Zack Snyder has
unleashed a lot of like behind the
scenes tidbits some photos and a little
bit of video here and there in regards
to what wasn't in the movie so if we can
see some of what he's been able to
complete so far not just cool concept
art or behind the scenes photography but
like no here's here's a snippet of some
stuff that we get here's a look at
Darkseid this could be really really
cool I can't wait to eat this up and as
far as James Gunn Suicide Squad movie
goes I could see a version we're not all
that like if they just do the whole
x-force thing x-force bit where they
kill them off I feel like I'm just gonna
be like a ripping off Deadpool - at that
point especially with one big giant
montage you're killing them off but I I
feel like some of them might die but I
also think you'll probably lean a little
bit more into the underdogs that just
sounds like what James gun style would
be seems like a James gonna kind of
thing to do is history of guardians it
would be funny if they killed off
boomerang and Harley Quinn in the
beginning ah that would go well that
would go great donor expectations
[Music]
because it's the last Jedi tell us
anything with Batman I think it's gonna
be really great you know I feel like
we'd finally get the chance to see
hopefully what Robert Pattinson is like
within the role would have gone kind of
feel that going for yeah I'm really
excited to see the tone because we've
had so many different Batman movies over
the years finally we get the chance to
see Matt Reeves and his interpretation
of it writing could be really cool you
know let's give a good little taste of
zoe kravitz love that girl you want a
taste of zoe kravitz a huh huh she's a
she's a cool person
she's a cool cat what to say now you're
not doing this as well as me
do we not did you not sleep Abbi okay so
with this event there's a lot of things
that we're expecting to see right what
we really need are some great surprises
the things that are just not being
talked about of what could possibly be
there like Green Lantern the HBO Mac
show because HBO max really needs them
so they need something there to doubt
that could totally be like didn't used
to come I mean and honestly the rock is
been talking about Black Adam since like
the dawn of time and so if he's actually
there at a panel then I feel like I
could finally be truly excited for the
rock to be in a black Adam movie it just
seems like one of those projects that
love I'm not sure I'll believe it until
it's actually there and like a lot of
the speculation hasn't really been about
the flash either maybe because I maybe
just consistently pushed all the time
there's a lot of other properties as
well that have been in development some
that have been can but the other ones
that have been just constantly pushed
that there's like of course we're gonna
see one or momin 84 Batman Suicide Squad
I'm excited to see what what's gonna
come over long gated man yeah he's in
the flash movie now he is no Harley
Sawyer he's in the flash movie that's
why he got fired from the show right
that makes sense
yeah I mean they they're moving him they
that's what the Ezra Miller thing was
setting up because they wanted them both
to be you know objective two women I
don't know what you're talking about I
thought he just did such a good job that
are putting I don't know was there some
piece of news that I missing handle
everyone who's canceled I think it's
something else
I heard Christie Elia just as hard to
work with didn't hear anything else
about guys are you excited this DC event
is happening separately you're excited
it's gonna be online leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification about subscriber
mergency awesome Erin Alexander follow
him online he's a sexy-ass poet wouldn't
you know it wouldn't you want to blow it
hell yeah gene Jeter are you drinking in
the middle of me shouting out a patron
gene gene Jeter is a wonderful person
puts together some of those strangest
but most amusing Trinita laughs you'll
ever see and I want to recommend here he
has a try not to laugh this one of
Tyrone Magnus and Skaar low edition
number two it's as bizarre as you'd
imagine it as difficult of a challenge
as you'd hope dies go check out this
challenge and see if you laugh or not
when trying not to laugh I've never
promoted to try not to laugh but guys go
check it out jeans been an incredible
supporter of the channel he's staying
alive in New York during a lot of
craziness going on over there stay safe
he's a good human being go follow him
today thanks gene